donc tout à l'heure on a parlé un petit
peu de choses sérieuses avec jean marais
vous je suis désolé je vous ai fait une
les questions nul
bon évidemment vous n'avez pas bougé par
le jingle et je vous en félicite
vous savez j'ai la chose la plus
importante pour moi dans cette émission
non mais c'est pas les questions nul de
d'habitude j'ai bossé cet été moi j'ai
pas j'ai bossé je vais préparer les
nouvelles halles à ce que je vous ai vu
dans les journaux en vacances il faut qu
mais maintenant j'ai vraiment bossé
parce qu'avant je vous disais vous
préférez votre père ou votre mère hitler
ou staline n'a pas du tout venant et là
l'extrait qu'on vient me voir
oui aurait inspiré la question s'il
n'avait pas déjà trouvé une vraie
différence des entre votre coupe de
cheveux votre coiffure dans l'extrait
convient de voir aujourd'hui est la
première question je suis une femme vous
laver les cheveux tous les combien tous
les jours ah d'accord
je fais maintenant tous les jours
toujours à bon j'étais raplapla à paris
c'était un peu gras mouillé la wii sur
l'extrait c'est normal
ah oui vous êtes en skiant sur scène
donne rarement
franchement si je fais un compliment en
forme ah oui je vous ai rarement vu
aussi chic aussi si propre à 18 soit
disant très bien le succès vous va bien
alors est ce que vous préférez attention
c'est assez compliqué est ce que vous
préférez un président de la république
d'extrême droite élu au suffrage
universel ou pas d'élection du tout la
direction dit pas d'élection du tout
fait pour la dictature à ce moment là
complètement ça revient au même
comme midi quelle différence y at-il
entre frédéric françois et françois
valéry à cela les yeux se jouera connect
s'il faut vraiment qu'il faut vraiment
des gens mois d'été
ils sont toujours là alors que les
légumes amant alors qu'est ce que vous
aimeriez avoir année supplémentaire un
avis supplémentaire un doigt un sexe et
si c'était un chèque supplémentaire
lequel ballet sexe de mon amant gaza une
bonne réponse
et comme les escargots comme ça pour s
ils sont pas chier des escargots un oui
quand même
ouais tu vois le bras d'honneur
confrères gonzesses on aura un sexe de
femme pas loin juste là à l'intérieur de
l'église
qu'est ce que tu fais ben tu vois je
baise
bush et à l'esprit vandry de la drogue à
la sortie des écoles si la survie de vos
enfants dépend des studios tels qu'ils
sont idiots et les monstres s'appelle
l'interview c'est le choix de sophie da
seulement
donc classer au bon niveau et je suis
mais loin de tout ça mais bon je prends
un passeport et je me casse loin de ce
monde pourri non mais tu peux décemment
tu peux pas de barre et à la question
c'est que tu es l'argent je peux
d'accord jusqu'à ses nuits je paie si
vous en aviez le pouvoir ou mettriez
vous parie sur la carte de france à
paris à paris s'il pleut toujours
officiellement sa campagne on sait bien
c'est super moi je crois je passe à un
moment merveilleux des contes que tu
t'en fous tu et à toi qui réussissent il
reprend la même la fin de la
conversation c'est vrai que 10 fait bobo
on est content
simple équation la lucette entendre
qu'elle était pour nous de faire de la
concurrence à la ménagère je peux avoir
la tient à la gorge
non mais c'est quoi ça vous êtes devenu
macho dans les bacs non pas du tout
match ou non c'est simplement que mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire quoi la
différence entre hétéros et macho je
vois pas ba a été rossé un match sympa
mais zéro qu'on bon si vous étiez en
vente dans un sex-shop vous seriez quoi
comme objet moi c'est le dernier
contient elle vibre commence à vibrer
bon dernière question qu'est bourboule
images de l'image la plus triste
une valve à sa fenêtre un chien perdu
sur une autoroute ou un dimanche devant
la télé une veuve à sa fenêtre non
triste c'est finalement devant la télé
mais tu peux dormir donc tu oublies
c'était pour sa fenêtre
ah ouais terrible ça de perdre son mari
est d'abord pas de fenêtre ça sera
encore bien des lunes vote on arrive à
ce qui a été fait appel à une fenêtre
c'est vrai qu'elle peut regarder la vie
et se dire que c'est possible de sauter
j'en arrive attendu par les deux d'elza
zylberstein des nouvelles qui va arriver
et dans lautrec le merveilleux film de
roger planchon il ya cette phrase
merveilleuse ou 4 la fille se fait
découper en tranches et tout est dit tu
veux mettre ça en image lui dit son
frère et lui dit non pas de pathétique
en peinture la cruauté tranquille du
quotidien suffit pas voilà la veuve à sa
tête merci jean marie bigard